THEY AREN’T THE FIRST NFL TEAM
TO STEP UP UP TO THE PANDEMIC.
NEW ENGLAND PATRIOTS BROUGHT
MORE THAN A MILLION TO NEW YORK.
PETE: PETE AMERICAN LEGION POST
LINING UP ON GEORGIA HIGHWAY
WITH A MILLION AMERICAN FLAGS.
COMMANDER OF THE AMERICAN LEGION
POST NUMBER 335 IN SYLVESTER,
GEORGIA, RAY HUMPHREY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
I’M A MEMBER OF 225 IN FOR REST
LAKE, MINNESOTA.
A FELLOW LEGIONNAIRE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE, WHAT
YOU DO THERE.
TALK TO AMERICANS ABOUT YOUR
EFFORT, WHAT YOU’RE DOING AND
WHY YOU’RE DOING IT?
>> WE STARTED GIVING LUNCHES TO
CHILDREN WHENEVER THEY WERE OUT
OF SCHOOL.
OUR POST HELPED WITH THAT.
WE WERE ASKING WHAT COULD WE DO
BESIDES THAT TO HELP THE
SITUATION.
A FRIEND OF MINE ROBERT GREER
CALLED ME IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT, TOLD ME I THINK WE NEED
TO SET UP THE FLAGS.
WE WERE THINKING ABOUT DOING
THAT ANYWAY.
WE THOUGHT ABOUT THE FACT DURING
WORLD WAR II WHEN PEARL HARBOR
WAS BOMBED, FLAGS CAME UP
EVERYWHERE.
9/11, FLAGS CAME UP EVERYWHERE.
WE DECIDED WE WOULD GET UP THAT
MORNING TO PUT FLAGS UP.
I PUT OUT A CALL.
I GOT FIVE PEOPLE AND A HOUND
DOG TO COME HELP US PUT THEM UP.
WE GOT THEM PUT UP.
THEY’RE SITTING THERE NOW.
WE HAVE A SIGN OUT ON THE FRONT
OF IT, TOGETHER WE ARE STRONG,
WE WILL SURVIVE THIS LIKE EVERY
OTHER CASE COMES BEFORE US, WE
HAVE SURVIVED IT.
PETE: RAY, I LOVE THAT.
SOMETIMES YOUR FRIEND CALLING
YOU IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
HAS THE BEST IDEA, SOMETIMES
NOT, BUT YOU RESPONDED AND I
LOVE IT.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT YOUR VETERAN
MILITARY BACKGROUND GIVES YOU
THE FORTITUDE IN THIS MOMENT
WHEN A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE ANXIOUS
AND UNCERTAIN?
>> YOU KNOW YOURSELF, WHEN
YOU’RE UNDER PRESSURE YOU MAKE
THE BEST DECISIONS, YOU DO THE
BEST THINGS.
YOU WILL MAKE IT COME THROUGH.
WE’RE GOING TO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
THE AMERICAN LIEGER ON IS HERE
FOR THE COMMUNITY.
WE’RE HERE FOR ALL OF THE
VETERANS, ALL OF OUR FORMER
WARRIORS.
WE’RE HERE TO SUPPORT THEM,
SUPPORT EVERYONE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
WE JUST WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT
WE’RE HERE.
WE’RE TOGETHER, WE’RE STRONG, WE
WILL SURVIVE.
PETE: RAY, SOMETIMES THAT IS
WHAT PEOPLE NEED.
SEEING OTHERS PEOPLE OUT THERE,
DISPLAYING THE PATRIOTISM,
UNAFRAID, COURAGEOUS, DISPLAYING
HOPE.
WE LOVE WHAT YOU’RE DOING AT
POST 335.
RAY HUMPHREY, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND A SHOT IN THE ARM
FOR YOU WILL OF US THIS MORNING.